direction versailles à présent la 7e
édition des olympiades s'est tenue ce
samedi au stade mont-boron le concept
une centaine de valider de personnes en
situation de handicap participent
ensemble à des ateliers sportifs pendant
la journée
au programme de l'équitation du football
de la natation encore de la pétanque
l'organisatrice de l'événement annie
bouquet était au micro de camille
lambert
le concept en fait c'est quand on est
face à une personne situation handicape
on va aller vers elle en disant je vais
faire une berge donc on va aller vers
cette personne on va comprendre quel est
son type d'handicap
on va s'adapter elle pour pouvoir
l'aider la compagnie et pour moi c'est
les bases du vivre ensemble
et d'ailleurs quand on fait ça on en a
on revient on est tous contents et donc
je veux dire c'est que pour le vivre
ensemble c'est aller vers l'autre
comprendre l'autre écouter quels sont
ses besoins et s'adapter à l'eau pour
faire passer un moment entre amis